INTERPRETER: I'm Lauren
Ridloff, and I play Makkari
in Marvel Studios' Eternals.
And this is "Power Words."
[MUSIC PLAYING]
In the movie, my
character's name is Makkari.
Sign it with me--
Makkari.
Did you get it?
Good.
Give yourself a thumbs up.
Makkari is one of the Eternals.
Sign it with me--
Eternals.
Did you get it?
Nice, you're doing well.
And the Eternals are my family.
Come on, sign it with me--
family.
Did you get it?
Family.
Good.
Give yourself a thumbs up.
Do you know how I tell my
family that I love them?
Sign it with me--
I love you.
Did you get it?
Aw, thank you.
I love you, too.
Now, sign with me.
Nice to meet you.
Did you get it?
Ah, very nice to meet you, too.
Ready to meet the Eternals?
[WHIRRING]
Ikarus-- powerful, brave.
Ajak-- leader, healer.
Sersi-- selfless, fearless.
Sprite-- youthful, adaptable.
Phastos-- innovator, genius.
Kingo-- influential, mighty.
Thena-- warrior, fierce.
Druig-- independent, persuasive.
Gilgamesh-- strong, loyal.
Makkari-- swift, daring.
That's me.
Did you get it?
We can't wait to meet you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
You know your power words.